- ♪ I'LL TREAT YOU RIGHT
- I WASN'T SURE IF LIZ WAS GONNA
COME THROUGH WITH A SPONSOR,
SO I SOLD SOME SPACE
ON MY DRESS.
DID YOU KNOW I CUT A DEAL
WITH SAN DIEGO DIET
BEFORE THE WEDDING?
- OH, MY GOD.
YOU'RE, LIKE, A GENIUS.
- WELL, I MIGHT HAVE STARTED
AT BINGHAMTON,
BUT I FINISHED AT SYRACUSE.
[slurps]
- ♪ YOU'LL ALWAYS BE
MY BEST FRIEND ♪
- IT'S LIKE I'VE BEEN JUGGLING
SO MANY BALLS.
BUT, LIKE,
TODAY IS MY DAY, OKAY?
- OKAY.
- GREAT.
- BUT, LIZ...
- WHAT?
- PROMISE ME ONE.
- TOTALLY.
- THAT THAT IS THE LAST BIT
OF WORK THAT YOU WILL DO TODAY.
- OKAY, FINE.
- LIZ.
- WHAT?
- I GOT SOMETHING FOR YOU.
CASSANDRA!
LIZ?
- YEAH?
- SOMETHING OLD...
- OKAY.
- SOMETHING NEW.
- LITTLE GLOVES.
SOMETHING BORROWED...
- UH-HUH.
- AND SOMETHING BLUE.
- OH, MY GOD, LOOKIT,
THOSE ARE NAUGHTY.
- HOLD ON.
- WHAT?
- [whispers]
THEY'RE ALL UNDER ARMOUR.
[romantic music swells]
- YOU DID GET A SPONSOR?
[fairy-like tinkling]
I LOVE YOU. LIZ.
- [squeaking] I LOVE YOU A LOT.
- EVERYTHING LOOKS AMAZING.
- THANK YOU.
- I DIDN'T THINK
I COULD EVEN...
- LIKE, YOU LOOK AMAZING!
- AND IT'S, LIKE,
I COULDN'T EVEN IMAGINE-- [sobs]
- I COULDN'T EVEN IMAGINE
IF SOMEONE WAS, LIKE--
[music stops suddenly]
- LADIES AND GENTLEMEN,
WELCOME TO THE LIVE STREAMING
PUBLIZITY WEDDING.
LIZ AND NNAMDI HAVE ACTUALLY
WRITTEN THEIR OWN VOWS,
WHICH IS FUN.
SO, LIZ,
IF YOU WANT TO GO FIRST.
- THANK YOU.
DEAR NNAMDI,
YOU WERE THE ONE FOR ME
FROM THE VERY START.
I KNEW THAT FROM THE DEPTHS
OF MY VERY DEPTH-FUL HEART.
[slurp]
WHETHER IT WAS WHEN I MET YOU
AFTER STALKING YOU
AFTER A GAME,
THINGS WITH--
ARE NEVER LAME WITH YOU.
[sighs]
- MM.
- THAT WAS BEAUTIFUL.
- THANK YOU.
- NNAMDI, GO AHEAD.
- LIZ...
I'M SO EXCITED TO BE GETTING
MARRIED TO YOU TODAY.
- THANK YOU.
- YOU SEEM LIKE A REALLY,
REALLY COOL CHICK.
AND I JUST WANT EVERYONE HERE
TO KNOW...
THAT YOU JUST GOT NNAMDI'D!
[applause, laughter]
- WHAT?
- THERE'S A CAMERA HERE,
CAMERA THERE, CAMERA HERE.
YOU JUST GOT NNAMDI'D.
- WHAT?
- ARE YOU SAYING
"WHAT" OR "WHY"?
- WHAT?
- IT DOESN'T MATTER, LOOK.
THAT "WHAT" IS,
THIS IS MY PRANK SHOW.
AND THE "WHY" IS,
BECAUSE YOU'RE A BEAST.
- I DON'T KNOW
WHAT JUST HAPPENED.
- GOOD JOB.
YOU'RE PAYING FOR IT.
- WAIT.
- [laughs]
- ♪ THE BEST IS
YET TO COME ♪
- LIZ, DID YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS?
OR, LIKE, WHAT?
- NO, BUT NOW I KNOW ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE PRANK JUST HAPPENED.
- [sobbing] BUT, LIKE,
THIS IS NOT EXACTLY
HOW I PICTURED
MY [stifled] WEDDING TO BE.
DO I JUST, LIKE,
WALK RIGHT NOW?
- YEAH, GO BACK THERE.
- JUST GO, LIKE--
YOU SHOULD PROBABLY,
LIKE, HEAD OUT.
- DO I JUST, LIKE,
WALK LIKE THIS, OR DO I--
- LIZ, I'M SO SORRY.
- ABOUT WHAT?
- THAT, LIKE,
YOUR WEDDING WAS RUINED,
AND YOU WERE PRANKED IN FRONT
OF, LIKE, NATIONAL TELEVISION.
LIKE, IT'S GOOD KARMA
THAT YOU LET HIM BE SUCCESSFUL
AT SOMETHING,
EVEN IF THAT WAS, LIKE,
TO COMPLETELY PRANK YOU
AND, LIKE, FOOL YOU
AND, LIKE,
CALL YOU A BEAST,
SAY THAT IT WAS HILARIOUS,
LIKE, MAKE YOU WEAR THAT HAT.
- YEAH.
- WHEN PUSH COMES DOWN TO IT,
LIKE, I'LL ALWAYS BE HERE
FOR YOU
BECAUSE YOU'RE
MY BEST FRIEND.
- I'M JUST
SO HAPPY THAT,
IF I HAD TO GET PRANKED
ON NATIONAL TELEVISION
BY A PROFESSIONAL
FOOTBALL PLAYER FOR HIS SHOW,
THAT YOU WERE BY MY SIDE
THE WHOLE TIME.
- YEAH.
- I'M NOT CRAZY, RIGHT?
- NO, YOU JUST GOT PRANKED.
- [slurps]
- DO I HAVE ANYTHING
IN MY TEETH?
- ♪ YOU'LL ALWAYS BE